"Заручники Путіна: українські політв'язні Кремля".
Фільм про понад 70 українців,
яких Росія утримує за ґратами, показали
у стінах Європарламенту.
- Одягали мені на голову кульок,
намагалися мене задушити,
знову і знову били...
Олега Сенцова незаконно утримують в Росії,
а Москва не реагує на міжнародні заклики і петиції...
-  Жоден із них ні в чому не винен. Цих людей
просто так кинули до в'язниць, щоб показати усім іншим,
що якщо ви підведете голову, якщо ви почнете боротися,
ми вас також посадимо у в'язницю.
Історію усіх українських заручників Кремля
фільм розповідає на прикладі Євгена Панова,
Геннадія Афанасьєва, Бекіра Дегерменджи та Павла Гриба.
Активіста й ветерана АТО Євгена Панова схопили у Криму,
засудили у справі так званих "українських диверсантів"
та вивезли в Омськ.
Геннадія Афанасьєва посадили у справі
про так звану "групу Сенцова".
Кримськотатарського активіста Бекіра Дегерменджи,
який активно боровся за звільнення інших затриманих,
нині судять за обвинуваченням у вимаганні грошей,
а студент Павло Гриб поїхав у Білорусь до дівчини
і там його викрали співробітники ФСБ Росії.
Нині хлопця судять у Ростові-на-Дону за тероризм.
Батько Павла каже: наступного тижня очікується вирок.
Йому загрожує до 10 років ув’язнення.
- Стан його погіршується. На чотирьох останніх
судових засіданнях підряд суд викликав швидку.
Швидка приїжджала, давала знеболювальне,
і суд продовжував свою діяльність далі...
Павло скаржиться на сильні болі у голові, у животі.
Враховуючи його хворобу...
Кров по зворотній вені погано постачається до головного мозку,
тремтіння рук дуже сильне,
порушення координації...
Ігор Гриб спеціально приїхав на показ до Брюсселя.
Він розповідає, що в сина невиліковна хвороба
кровоносної системи.
Павлу терміново потрібна операція,
інакше хлопець може померти. Проте,
за словами батька, більше року російська влада
навіть не дозволяла передавати бранцю ліки,
необхідні для підтримки здоров'я.
Приїхав до Брюсселя і Віктор Сорока,
батько офіцера СБУ - одного з 24 військових та моряків, -
захоплених Росією поблизу Керченської протоки
у листопаді минулого року. У Москві їх судять
за "незаконний перетин кордону", а Україна вважає
військовополоненими. Василь Сорока був
поранений під час захоплення українських кораблів.
Нещодавно йому зробили операцію в СІЗО.
Та як вона пройшла, рідні не знають.
- За 115 днів, відколи син перебуває у полоні,
у нас ніяких контактів, ніяких телефонних дзвінків не було,
зустрічі забороняють
Кінопоказ організувала група депутатів Європарламенту.
Серед них - Марк Демесмакер із фракції
"Європейські консерватори та реформісти"
та Ребекка Гармс із фракції Зелених.
- Сфабриковані докази, тортури, недопущення
до медичної допомоги, що також є тортурами, -
усе це змушує мене почуватися безсилим, адже
не так багато ти можеш зробити, бо розумієш,
із яким режимом ми маємо справу.
- Страждання політв'язнів з України, деяких із яких
просто викрали і тримають у російських в'язницях,
повинні стати набагато більш відомими.
Ще мене вразили страждання матерів, батьків,
сестер, братів, друзів кожного з цих політв'язнів.
Путін спричинив надзвичайно багато страждань
тим, що захопив цих заручників.
За останні роки Європарламент ухвалив
не одну резолюцію з вимогою звільнити всіх
українських політв'язнів у Росії і в Криму.
Наприкінці 2018 присудив режисеру Олегу Сенцову
премію Сахарова. Проте важіль справжнього
впливу на Росію - це санкції, вважає Марк Демесмакер.
- Ми повинні зберігати тиск. Ми не повинні забувати,
що не лише Україна, не лише жителі Криму
є жертвами. Путін іде далі, він робить мішенню нас,
нашу демократію та нашу єдність.
Я сподіваюся, санкції вдасться зберегти та,
можливо, посилити. Це єдина мова,
яку такі диктатори розуміють.
Уже після виходу стрічки про 70 заручників Кремля
у лютому 2019-го російські силовики
затримали ще трьох кримських татар. Загалом
ідеться про понад 200 українців, яких в Росії
утримують за політичними обвинуваченнями.
Разом із моряками, яких захопили в Чорному морі,
та бранцями бойовиків на  окупованих територіях Донбасу.